ecco qui questi cosa sono panca nam sta
bene a tutti i ragazzi e benvenute
questo nuovo video io sono pari j
oggi siamo su uno dei videogame più
amati di tutti i secoli ragazzi voglio
dirvi una cosa secondo voi io voglio
sottratto dalle vacanze in questi ultimi
giorni vi ho chiesto sulla pagina
facebook quali fossero i videogame che
io avrei dovuto giocare al mio ritorno
indovinate qual è stata la prima
richiesta maledizione sta roba ogni
volta che pensiamo di liberarsene
ritorna maledetto non era morto era una
finzione
vabbè iniziamo e perché non si può
andare avanti così a dalla prima o poi
finiranno ve lo giuro ragazzi blow
prometto ve lo prometto che finiranno
edizione gli alba quando gli alberi
hanno le spine cos'è allora ragazzi
abbiamo appena iniziato tutti molto
calmi alla l'abbiamo capito che sto
albero qui non si deve saltare bene ok
perfetto adesso anche le colline hanno
le spine giusto ora ragazzi le colline
hanno le spine prossimamente nei cinema
ci ho fatto ragazzi quasi sicuro c'è una
trappola probabilmente la moneta mi
ucciderà non lo so io ci provo
[Risate]
c'è un [ __ ] cubo questo l'abbiamo
capito ok ok camica micah micah missimi
khamis
col mister c'è ragazzi adesso mi dovete
spiegare perché sto facendo il moonwalk
non lo so cioè io vado avanti e questo
ce vado non lo so ragazzi
tutti i caldissimi beh questo è facile
ce la posso fare allora ragazzi non ce
la faccio perché non ce la faccio perché
da quando le nuvole cadono raga non lo
so ma che mario mi batto si può più
sclerare in tutti gli altri non ha senso
come faccio qui come fa si è bloccato
sembrata troppo cari quella
maledettissima nuvola
non è possibile che non ce la faccio se
io posso continuare a fare così però
rinuncia a fare un mai maledizione via
così via così via così
ok ok addio si sa se ce l'ha fatta
ce l'ho fatta oddio cos'erano io sono
passato le retrò frates
ok non è una cosa normale che dei troll
face ci siamo super mario
ancora lui che mario passa in seconda
posizione se ne salta tre ancora lui
ancora lui
incredibile la bandiera la bandiera l'ho
presa l'ho preso l'ho preso l'ho preso
l'ho presa e l'ho presa e l'ho presa
presa
hand made by dj regia ce l'ho fatta ok
come al solito è meglio che me ne sto
zitto va beh no no no no niente
continueranno a fare così per il resto
nel vino
[Musica]
buone notizia ce l'abbiamo fatta no
perfetto questo pezzo era uguale a
quello dell'altro che mario perfetto lo
sapevo che c'era qualcosa c'è una pianta
qui c'è una pianta periodo andare qui
sotto o andare qui sotto calmi si ok ci
siamo sul nuovo livello ci siamo
conoscitive ok ok ok ok ok un cazzo
perché sto morendo duemila volte ma ci
sono ben e laica ce la stiamo
sì io devo starmene zitto perché è
meglio
ok vuoi così ok kami tali un cazzo che
mi incazzo col valiamo saliamo saglia
cos'è questo non lo so non so cos'è
cos'è
oh mio dio sono diventato un nano va
bene allora gara non penso sia ok non
dovevo prenderlo quel [ __ ] fondo
giornali questi mi dovranno fare santo
per quello che sto facendo
cos'è cos'è la finta era finita sta roba
già adesso anche le colonne finte mi
sembra impossibile
lo farò tutto quanto adesso fino alla
fine allora ce la posso fare voi non
credete in me lo so ma io ce la faccio
un tubo incredibile come faccio a sapere
che morì nozze ci mandate sinchetto
mario c'è ma siamo questo effetti stato
centro mai cosa ti sei fumato
mio zio ok ragazze dopo solamente se non
mi schiacciano i conti le nostre se devo
farmi che ok ok effettivamente sì
qualcosa mischiarlo sicuro a meno che io
non devo passare sulle ponete sopra le
monete io pensavo che c'era la casella
sotto le monete che rimaneva in piedi no
infatti ci provo
in qualche modo non lo so ma poi sono
mica tutte giuste c'è qualcuno è
sbagliata cesarano lo so ride o di vento
allor cos'è sta roba cotanti tubi ci
sono fatemi capire quante va beh devo
100 euro pallina
c'è di sopra non ci arrivo ragazzo un
punto interrogativo non ci arriva per un
importo cos'è cazzo addio
cos'è che cazzo succede no vabbè raga è
uscita una tartaruga cosa mi serve
by john è andata davvero giù andata
veramente giu ci devo andare giù o dio
cos'è io non so quanto va beh siamo
usciti oddio ragazzo abbassando di sotto
non so se si passa effettivamente di
sotto ci provo tanto è una trappola lo
so che è una trappola per ci provo lo
stesso vai o pardon non volevo rompere
va bene ok sono morto perché mercato non
mi è cascata la bandiera addosso bene
ragazzi è successo cosa devo fare qui
dello stato sa cos'è lawford chiesto
cos'è sta roba mi odi o distrutto la
bandiera no infatti sono morto raga è in
possesso
rendetevi conto che questo è il cat
mario più strano che io abbia mai fatto
non ha senso
vabbè allora bandiera l'ho distrutta go
for the ok va bene allora questo qua lo
salto questo ok perfetto questo non lo
so raga non so qual è il castello giusto
penso sia questo non lo so raga il mio
dio allora macello
ma verona che ha visto dirette ricordo
sia facile fare questo livello per me
cos'è questa roba sono caduti e super
sayan ha al contrario bene bene normale
è tutto normale skiff ai super sayan ok
ecco qui questi cosa sola banca arner st
[Musica]
[Applauso]
allora voi mi dovete spiegare che cosa
ci fa il gun gun file il jet mario 4 c'è
ma va beh io non ho parole
e ti ammazza pure da te non guardatelo
guardate guarda o dio è partito un
albero lo avete parte va beh devo andare
avanti perfetto ce la faccia a faccia
faccio fantasmino maledetto sì no no no
no sarà una cosa impossibile è
impossibile non è nel mio vocabolario
ce la posso fare oddio cosa è quello s'è
messo spara cos'è cos'è cos'è cosas
cos'è raga cosa sta succedendo ragan un
cammino me nel senso di sorteggio che si
butta giù col paracadute ma vabbè c'è la
bandiera lì ok la bandiera l'ho presa il
tizio non ho capito bene che ci sta a
fare ma non importa invece il fungo c'è
un altro cos'è sto per questo fungo e
verde cosa mi cambia cos'è è dimesso
affinché tu mario verde va bene così
dalle ragazze andiamo avanti
e ovvio che quando vai avanti ed enti di
superare un punto ci sono degli alberi
che cascano giusto deve essere l'albero
di prima che si sta schiantando di nuovo
sulla terra fantastica la possiamo fare
cosa sono sti cosi raga non lo staff
perché primario a foglia oddio c'è
questo cos'è c'è ragazza a diventarne
una cosa impossibile non ha senso
c'è allora che mario mi affoga escono in
fantasmi suv c'è spongebob che cazzo ci
fa la cosa brutta rega che non mi
ricordo dove sporge mi pare fosse in
questa è già fatta ce l'ho fatta carmi
ce l'ho fatta c'è uno stronzo bob
acquatico che esce va bene così bene
quando mandare in questa per forza
perché non ci vedo altre soluzioni bene
così
un troll face subacqueo dopo questa non
viste tutte vai vai vai vai sì sì sì sì
non ci credo bene ce la posso fare
allora c'è il fantasmino che non
schiaccio perché ha paura che mi
ammazzino stesso vai così non so che
cosa c'è un mio dio
ovvio dio chiuso fatto questo fatto
saltato di tutto saltato di tutto va
bene
va bene va bene va bene
raga psi spongebob di tutto trofei
subacquee di tutto c'era non importa ce
l'ha fatta
cos'è ragazzi adesso c'è un ascensore
anche giusto raga mi sa che per questo
episodio la chiudo qui perché cadono le
nuvole
quindi ragazzi 6 video è piaciuto
lasciato commento mi piace anche la
pagina di facebook e come in ogni vita
ho aspettato un attimo che ti sto
facendo è troppo è troppo tranquillo e
troppo tranquilli cos'è sta roba
si è alzato va bene pavimento non
importa se ragazzi braga non ci credo
non ci credo che cazzo successo no dai
non potete lasciarmi cos'è direi che lo
continuo il prossimo episodio rimango
qui così non ho fatto figure di merda
nel finale
fortunatamente la prima volta sarebbe la
vera galla chiudo più per questo
episodio io presumo che nei prossimi
succederà il delirio i ragazzi seguito è
piaciuto lasciato un commento mi piace
anche la pagina di facebook e come in
ogni video trovate nella descrizione se
non siete ancora iscritti gli scriventi
e noi ci rivediamo il prossimo vito bene
ragazzi